on passe au focus people ce mardi est
sorti sur Netflix
Pamela Love Story c'est un documentaire
dans lequel face caméra les affres de
son existence elle parle de tout la
sextape tout pourquoi parce que Disney
plus ça avait sorti justement une série
sur elle sur la sextape voilà elle a
voulu du coup c'est très bien foutu elle
a voulu dire toute la vérité sa vérité
elle est le style de pas être maquillée
d'être voilà plein cam comme ça d'être
vrai en entier dans sa maison de
colourbe britannique où elle est née où
il y a sa mère on voit sa mère on la
voit voilà dans la vie de tous les jours
c'est un très très beau doc sur Netflix
regardez le récap et on a Fabien le cœur
qui l'a très bien connu qui était son
agent
[Musique]
en posant entièrement nu pour un
magazine américain cette semaine Pamela
Anderson nous prouve qu'elle n'a rien
perdu de son goût pour la provoque et
pour le business
car cette semaine c'est également la
sortie événement de son autobiographie
Love et surtout de son documentaire sur
Netflix dans lesquels l'actrice de 55
ans se met aussi à nu mais
émotionnellement cette fois-ci
[Applaudissements]
dans favela love story produit par l'un
de ses fils la bimbo la plus célèbre du
monde se confie sur sa vie tumultueuse
sans filtre ni maquillage
dans ce film de deux heures l'actrice
d'Alerte à Malibu revient entre autres
sur son adolescence très difficile au
cours de laquelle elle a été violée par
un homme de 25 ans la star ne cache rien
et passe même en revue sa longue et
délicate vie sentimentale de plus le
réalisateur a pu puiser dans la
collection d'archives personnelles de la
star ce qui doit au documentaire une
ambiance intimiste et 100% inédite bref
si vous aimez les success stories
hollywoodienne mélodramatique Pamela
Love Story était de manquer sous aucun
prétexte
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
explique que c'est très difficile de
courir au ralenti parce que du coup eux
ils filent normal donc il faut faire des
grands grands gestes quand tu cours pour
qu'après au ralenti plus que passer hein
j'aurais pu est-ce que tu sais Mathieu
pourquoi c'était au ralenti les scènes
où elle court non c'est que le
producteur qui a présenté le projet à
Hollywood il avait pas assez d'argent
pour faire un teaser ou assez long donc
je vais mettre des scénosaures plus
longtemps et c'est devenu ça qui a fait
le plus grand succès de pamelanque
on fait du slow motion
après la
normale
tu savais que c'était tellement pollué à
l'endroit
leur faisait des traitements réguliers
pour vérifier que sur le plan épiderme
c'était la scène quoi c'était une
décharge merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
vous étiez attaché de presse bien sûr à
l'époque mais vraiment dans les années
en plus Alerte à Malibu au moment où ça
cartonnait à partir de février 97 je me
suis occupé de la sortie de son livre
ouais elle était venue en France et
cetera elle était adorable d'ailleurs
elle est adorable dans la vie ah oui
adorable sympathique comme tout avec des
sujets et puis elle était dans son
compte de fait parce que c'est un conte
de fée elle s'ouvre expliqué quand elle
est repérée elle démarre sa carrière de
manière hasardeuse en 1988
tout ça parce qu'elle est elle est
canadienne avant couvert et alors c'est
quand même fantastique parce qu'elle a
un t-shirt avec une marque de bière et
le cadreur un des réalisateurs l'apprend
au milieu du public ouais dans un match
de basketball exactement et à partir de
là il la repère et il y a tellement
d'audience au moment où elle est avec la
masse
fantastique et d'un seul coup finalement
la marque de bière langage et à tout de
suite à lire à faire les photos pour
Playboy et Playboy il appelle derrière
pour lui dire mais la marque de bière
est génial elle commence ses cours de
Playboy à la fête 14 plus tous les
hors-série ça représente à peu près 25
ou qui sont ce qui sortent à peu près
dans 30 pays c'est d'un seul coup elle
est star en même pas 18 mois alors on va
voir la bande-annonce c'est un doc qui a
réalisé par son fils Brandon elle a deux
fils qu'ils les fils de Tommy Lee qui
sont magnifiques d'ailleurs absolument
si ils sont un peu
qui m'écrivent donc voilà on lit elle a
écrit des journaux intimes depuis le
début de sa vie qu'elle a qu'elle a
accepté que la journée utilise elle elle
voulait pas les lire ou elle raconte
tout c'est un très très beau vraiment
j'ai adoré de regarder la bande-annonce
[Musique]
je vais essayer d'aller un peu sur les
trucs les plus les plus forts parce que
elle est mignonne mais en même temps
elle est tellement innocente un peu
nunuche par exemple elle s'est mariée 5
fois dans une fois deux fois avec le
même son fameux mari c'est omélie
voilà et on va dans le doc que elle le
connaît quand elle l'épouse elle dit je
me connaissais même pas son nom de
famille elle a passé quatre jours avec
non mais elle est contre dans la nuit du
31 décembre au 1er janvier 1995 parce
qu'elle venait de sortir d'une histoire
amoureuse avec un chanteur plus avant
David Charvet voilà il est resté un an
et demi avec lui et puis en février tout
de suite derrière 95 elle l'épouse c'est
à dire vraiment trois deux mois après
l'avoir rencontré elle tombe folle
amoureuse alors vous savez le côté
oui
mais surtout non et ce qui est assez
amusant c'est parce que ce qu'il
excitait chez ce mec par rapport à tous
ces autres mecs vous le rappeler parce
que elle était bon bateau
les années 90 mais la Anderson
indiscutablement alors après situation
de bois de couleurs mais quand même et
elle le ski excitait le plus chez ce mec
on a parlé c'était les piercings je sais
pas si vous avez des piercings au sang
d'accord donc
en fait et en fait il a il a les deux
tétons percés avec ce persil et pour
Mathilde c'est ce qu'il y a de plus
excitant chez un type quand
est-ce qui est intéressant c'est que
elle dit donc je découvre dans le doc
qu'elle a été violée deux fois et elle
dit j'aime les bad boys en fait les mecs
un peu gentil ça m'ennuie j'aime les
mecs qui me traitent un peu mal quoi
elle est dans un espèce de truc un peu
délirant comme ça
on voit bien que la chatte c'est une
relation destructrice chaque fille a son
fantasme ça après chacun mais c'est vrai
qu'elle est peut-être à cette forme de
brutalité encore une fois de plus
sexuelle et alors donc là sextape on
apprend qu'effectivement parce que
pendant très longtemps on a tous douté
de cette sextape parce qu'elle a
vraiment été volée est-ce qu'elle l'a
fil à quelqu'un pour on apprend que la
sextape elle également été évolué dans
un coffre en plein travaux mais quelle
histoire parce qu'en fait le plombier
cette histoire de sexe
histoire mais non
il décide de faire des travaux
d'électricité dans leur maison de Los
Angeles et à ce moment-là l'électricien
qui vient amener sa facture à Tommy Lee
qui était là refuse de la payer il lui
met un flingue sur la tempe
parce qu'il faut reprendre toute
l'histoire et à partir de là lui se
venge récupère une cassette qui était
restée dans le magnéto de la chambre et
il a visionne déjà avec son
collaborateur il dit c'est très bien on
va réussir à se faire payer je pense
parce que lui son idée c'est de la
mettre de la diffuser sur tous les
réseaux Florian absolument mais à partir
de là c'est voilà il y a cette forme de
chantage les boys la paix lui propose 5
millions de dollars pour qu'elle soit
diffusée elle dit non non elle commence
à être diffusée partout et là c'est la
descente d'en faire pour elle pour lui
comme il est un peu Rockstar ça passe
mais pour elle on va être très honnête
ça devient un peu bah la bimbo nunuche
et c'est dangereux pour ses contrats
surtout bah est-ce qu'il y a tout est
bien marqué donc
surtout dans le dans le doc elle parle
de ce fameux cette fameuse série Disney
plus qui est sorti en disant ça m'a
brisé le cœur qui remettent cette vidéo
que je n'ai jamais vu et que je ne veux
jamais voir et c'est pourquoi parce qu'à
ce moment elle devient finalement un
objet pour les hommes et elle dit les
hommes m'appelaient par exemple il y a
un extrait où elle dit Sylvester
Stallone Rocky m'appelle un jour et me
dit je fais pas mal d'imitation
je t'offre une Porsche un appartement et
tu deviens ma première petite copine il
y a 10 sous-entendu qu'il y en a
d'autres derrière c'est que les hommes
l'appelle comme un objet et ça ça tombe
tout le temps de commerce dessus
en même temps j'ai beaucoup de respect
pour Pamela et ce genre de femme à qui
on a fait croire qu'elles avaient que
leur physique pour pouvoir exister et ne
pas montrer autre chose et ça ça a été
je pense la plus grande tristesse
il y a un business autour donc mon
instrumentalise quand même un petit peu
toutes ces histoires d'abord les stars
si elles n'ont pas d'histoire sont pas
des stars il faut quand même remettre
ben oui non mais c'est ça si on a des
histoires qui vont faire que ça a
provoquer des coups de magazine on va en
parler sur les radios sur les chaînes de
télé d'un seul coup vous existez deux
fois plus que les autres donc elle est
d'une très grande intelligence moi
c'était ma question moi je te promets
j'ai vu le doc c'est moi je vois comme
une fille qui s'est fait porter alors il
y a une pub pipelay boy elle s'est fait
déplacer comme ça moi je vois une fille
un peu bébête elle est tombée dans tous
les pièges PAM Anderson je posais la
question est-ce qu'elle est pas un peu
elle s'est fait porter par la vie comme
ça parfois elle se marie elle connaît la
personne depuis 12 jours depuis 7 jours
alors elle fait démarrer dans le doc
elle part un peu nunuche elle fait des
mariages elle comprend pas ce qui lui
arrive elle est en bikini puis après
elle dit tous les hommes me trouvent
trop jolie et moi et moi je veux jouer
du Molière bah non ma fille tu vois non
non mais tout ça je crois que
ça va être très intelligent mais
j'arrive fille intelligente d'abord il y
a quatre avocats derrière le premier
contrat avec Playboy déjà d'une part
mais surtout vous savez c'est un jeu de
rôle il y a une composition parmi toutes
les grandes personnalités de la planète
souvent quand elles font des carrières
comme ça fulgurantes avec un succès
planétaire d'abord il y a des hommes
d'affaires derrière et c'est un jeu de
rôle elle joue un personnage bien sûr
faut jamais l'oublier donc
je crois pas je crois je crois pas
qu'elle a plus d'argent du tout bien sûr
pourquoi pas mais tout ça c'est écrit
ces scénarisé ah bon mais bien sûr sinon
il y a rien dans le documentaire si vous
si vous expliquez en train de vendre
donc aux gens on nous proposons puis
pendant une heure et demie non mais vous
savez il y a toujours deux lectures sur
ce genre de documents et alors le fameux
Tommy qui était son mari à la fin il se
battent ils se battent ils se battent
elle appelle la police lui va en prison
il a pas le voir ses enfants enfin c'est
un peu compliqué ces deux fils qui
tournent maintenant et elle dit que
Tommy la dernière année de Baywatch
c'est-à-dire que Malibu c'était
tellement compliqué il venait en régie
tout le temps il était derrière la
caméra il
est-ce qu'elle est Mythos quand elle dit
par exemple qu'elle a été violée deux
fois elle raconte dans le doc j'ai été
violée une fois à 14 ans avec elle
baby-sitter non j'ai tellement souhaité
dans ma tête sa mort le lendemain elle
meurt aux actions de voiture elle dit
aussi qu'elle a essayé de la poignardée
me parler des baleines parce qu'elle a
une passion pour les baleines ah oui par
exemple elle me parle et puis la
communication avec elle c'était
compliqué parce que c'était payant au
quart d'heure d'interview c'est une
blague non non pas du tout c'est-à-dire
que c'est pour ça que c'était très
compliqué elle l'avait fait j'avais fait
faire que deux grandes interviews parce
qu'il y avait deux magazines à l'époque
qui ont pu payer je crois l'équivalent
de 50000 francs on était en France
encore en 1997 et donc il y avait et
puis c'était une association son livre
était sorti à la fois chez Valérie rétro
et chez newlook et donc entrevue avait
acheté une interview et dès qu'on
dépasse d'une minute c'était 5000 francs
[Rires]
juste revenir sur deux choses la
première c'est la fameuse sextape qui
est la raison pour la pour laquelle on
parle encore de Pamela Anderson tu veux
dire bah oui parce que ça c'est parce
qu'elle raconte dans le doc dans le doc
elle dit qu'ils avaient un coffre-fort
absolument dans lequel il y avait
notamment cette cassette un jour disparu
comme par enchantement et que Tommy Lee
un jour et lui dit donc la cassette il
dit il y a eu deux mois de travaux il y
avait des armes aussi j'ai pas vu j'ai
pas vu les ouvriers passés et un jour il
dit j'ai vu que le coffre était plus là
voilà donc cette histoire de menace etc
qui effectivement a été racontée à une
époque finalement est faux donc on peut
légitimement penser que peut-être pas
elle mais qu'en tout cas Tommy Lee et
peut-être complice de cette fuite à une
époque où les sextape n'existaient pas
encore et où ça a fait d'elle finalement
une pionnière et peut-être pour toutes
les décennies suivantes la plus célèbre
en la matière parce que qui sait pas
mais Anderson à part un objet de désir
sexuel dans dans Alerte à Malibu c'était
une mauvaise actrice mais elle était là
pour sa poitrine et sa beauté elle est
la record woman des Unes de Playboy et
depuis qu'est-ce qu'elle a fait et
depuis qu'est-ce qu'elle a fait si c'est
pas que ça aussi depuis qu'est-ce
qu'elle
fait on est là on dit que c'est une
actrice plaisir on dit que c'est une
actrice un peu bébête mais c'est vrai
que c'était la première à s'engager par
exemple pour la cause animale c'est elle
qui a d'abord c'est en ça qu'on va
revenir sur Bordeaux d'abord là où je
trouve toujours
c'est que tu dis c'est une actrice qui a
été dans la série la plus vendue dans le
monde rien que ça c'est une carrière
déjà c'est sûr évidemment il y a un vrai
comparant à faire avec Brigitte Bardot
c'est les hommes m'ont fait du mal et en
vieillissant j'étais un objet pour les
hommes je m'éloigne des hommes et
maintenant elle est à fond dans une
association protection des animaux au
point même d'avoir vu Poutine et
maintenant elle est dans sa famille avec
ses animaux et ses chiens alors la
comparaison avec Bardot c'est pas un
homme toujours quand on la compare à
Bordeaux parce que c'est le physique des
femmes enfants
le voit derrière vous regardez
totalement belle de mou à la barre d'eau
un peu comme ça donc ça c'est la
comparaison elle est là parce qu'elle
elle a eu ce même sexe à pile en tout
cas auprès des hommes parce que c'est un
c'est un physique qui est que les hommes
aiment bien ces femmes enfants un peu
voilà qui est là je donne la parole mais
un truc elle dit qu'elle savait qu'elle
faisait une émission de télévision et
c'est vrai il y a beaucoup d'extraits on
la voit faire des LED show avec plein de
plein de d'animateurs
mais incroyable vas-y montre tes seins
ils sont gros Tessin tu aimes bien faire
l'amour des questions quoi c'est
horrible on poserait jamais évidemment
et elle dit la misogynie des médias j'en
ai énormément souffert en semaine
au bout d'un moment quand tu fais la
magazine porno tout le temps et on va
t'étonner que sur les plateaux on peut
rien dire d'autre à une femme qui s'y
fait des magazines un peu dénudés tu
pourras lui parler d'autre que il avait
mentors une de Playboy à poil bah
l'animateur fasse une blague sur tes
seins ça paraît pas aberrant ça vous
intéresserait pas vous de savoir ce
qu'il y a à côté si toi tu avais été
mathématiciennes je t'aurais fait
résoudre une équation triple tu veux le
faire bon ben voilà
non mais c'est pas le cas alors pardon
excuse-moi on va parler à quelqu'un un
business tout est scénarisé moi
là-dessus je voilà
ils ont utilisé un talent au départ
physique évidemment eu des audiences
parce qu'on oublie de parler qu'elle
apparaît dans une émission de télévisée
aux États-Unis c'est des audiences de
malade série la plus vendu dans le monde
exactement quand il sort Playboy pour
qu'on fait 14 coups de Playboy rien
qu'en numéro mensuel et après je parle
pas tous les hors-série il y en a encore
une quinzaine mais pourquoi parce
qu'elle vend du papier
watch oh c'est beaucoup de il y a un
cachet original et puis après il y a il
y a son salaire par jour mais 250000
dollars par épisode à peu près c'est à
peu près j'aurais dû 300000 dollars à
peu près pareil
pour pour participer à la série bien sûr
elle peut faire rien alors à côté
évidemment trois hommes et un couffin
donc je pense qu'elle va à mon avis de
me proposer un Armentières moi c'est
Mathieu qu'est-ce que tu veux dire vous
êtes sûr qu'il est pas dans trois hommes
[Applaudissements]
découvert quand même la voix au bimbo
c'était la première bimbo et ensuite il
y a eu par ici
sur cette image de Pamela Anderson et
après rentrer dans le monde
et tout ça non mais elle a eu elle a eu
ce truc là de bimbo qu'elle a
complètement assumé et moi je trouve que
effectivement elle a cette vie un peu
comme Marilyn Monroe avec des hommes
toxiques ou elle sait jamais
véritablement trouvé donc elle est assez
touchante je trouve dans le
dossier de Tommy
mais d'accord c'est pas le même niveau
mais c'est le même genre de toxicité
avec les hommes en fait
j'avouablement j'avais pas bossé le
dossier mais Fabien m'a donné envie de
travailler story donc où est-ce qu'on
peut trouver cette [__] de cassette
génial et je rencontre pas la fin mais
elle est assez triste et ce qui est beau
c'est que voilà il y a des passages où
on lit son journal intime ce qu'elle
avait écrit à l'époque ce qu'elle vivait
et la meilleure te l'ai filmé et la fin
du doc et quand même très très beau et
vous vous dites que la vie c'est un peu
une cloche quand même c'est à dire qu'on
est on veut territoire on veut les
étoiles on veut tout ça et puis
finalement et d'ailleurs et ben on
retourne chez papa maman dans la maison
sans maquillage avec des chiens elle
parle de rami ou pas alors elle en parle
un petit peu mais je veux pas elle en
parle un elle dit un mot elle dit que
c'était aussi une relation un peu
toxique pas possible également elle dit
avec un footballeur français elle dit
pas le nom c'est toxique voilà comme
j'en sais rien là-dessus je vais pas
là-dedans il faut savoir que c'était en
2019 et depuis elle s'est déjà mariée
avec deux hommes différents
mais elle tombe c'est une amoureuse née
et elle a besoin de ça c'est son moteur
est pas en 4 jours moi je trouve
quelqu'un elle peut être sincère si
j'avais dû me marier avec les gens avec
qui j'ai couché non mais par contre je
la pense non mais je la pense
sincèrement honnête et sincère dans ses
relations avec les hommes maintenant
j'aurais des bagues de partout
elle s'est mariée quand elle s'est
mariée à Cancun ils ont pas mis de
bagues ils se sont fait tatouer la bague
avec le prénom en fait merci Fabien
Lecoeuvre voilà encore une fois plein
d'infos